hello everyone and welcome to a very
exciting game from round eight of the
2019 sinful cup it's a Segway kurakin
versus maxim Varsha holograph and it
seems like well from the last few games
that we've covered by MVL that when he
has the black pieces people-eater
challenged him to an idol or they
challenge him to a groom filled this is
one such case where Cara King challenges
him to a nice groom felt game and they
follow the same game they played in 2018
Norwich a championship with a nice
improvement from kurakin or or perhaps
it's not a nice improvement we'll just
have to check it out MC so without
further ado carotene opens with d4 with
Knight to f6 c4 g6 Knight to c3 and d5
the groom fell defense is on the board
we have C captors Knight captures efore
kicking away the knight Knight captures
and c3b captures and Bishop to g7 the
main line with Bishop to c4 and now c5
so Shawn just charging the center Knight
to e2 preparing the castle with Knight
to c6 by black putting more pressure on
the center and now Bishop to e3 adding
more defenders to the center with
castles by maksim castles by kurakin and
not b6 going for a nice pawn sacrifice D
captures on c5 we have Queen to c7
allowing even see captures and b6 but
this was only played a few times in the
white never really had any success with
it so players pretty much abandoned the
idea so tonight the d4 now you block the
bishops attack towards the c3 pawn and
also you are hoping for Knight captures
here so you can improve your pawn
structure of course maxime didn't
sacrifice a pawn for that with Knight to
e5 now attacking the bishop on c4 and
now comes Knight the b5 with an attack
on the Queen on c7 Queen to be eight and
now Bishop to d5 just attacking that
rock over there
they're in there 2018 or Norway Norway
championship at Bishop to e2 was played
by Carlton but here Bishop to d5 is a
different idea and it's
move Maxime played with the white pieces
against the board is getting fun but
we're gonna get back to that so the rook
is under attack but first Knight to g4
you offer a look for a nice mate on h2
so of course White has to prevent this
with g3 fermenting mate Knight captures
on e3 now attacking the Queen F captures
and here comes a six a big mistake would
be Bishop to b7 but even this was played
in one game then white continued just c6
pushing the bishop back and after Bishop
takes rook captures on f7 and now black
just falls apart the row capture special
characters and you cannot capture the
bishop if you capture dervish if you get
Queen d5 check and now you're getting
destroyed whatever you do if it's just
the Queen to d7
I for example King e8 you're gonna go
rook f1 there's a really no good way to
prevent Queen g8 mate
well of course butcher blocks and then
Queen captures an F it will be made as
the pawn covers the d7 square but even
this was played here with a6 the move
the move board is gave and played
against Maxine for Sheila Grove and here
Knight the d4 in that game Maxime played
Bishop captures on f7 against the
board's girlfriend in the 2013 World Cup
also played in in Norway but that game
ended in a draw of course a Giffen did
not capture and allow Queen to d5
Gelfand just played King h8 and then the
game just continued and ended in a draw
but here after a six with nice to d4
just nicely retreating the rook is still
under attack and it is as a move 17 that
we have a completely new game so and a
new move by Kerrigan B captures on c5
pushing the knight back a slight
improvement the be captures and c5 is
Bishop to h3 right away just developing
attacking the rook on f1 because after
be captures and c5 kirkin gets a ruby
one in this times we wouldn't attack on
the Queen so it's a slight improvement
Queen to a 7 and the now Knight to c6 so
not not giving up the night for rook
this way
Kerrigan wants to grab the e7 point as
well with checks so first knight c6
attacking the Queen preparing to
honey seven with Quinta c7 and mountain
night captures on e7 with check so
picking up a pawn queen captures and the
now bush of character Sunday 8 grabbing
the exchange but it's not a problem
Bishop to h3 now if you don't want to
lose your Bishop on a8 you have to give
up the exchange back so Bishop back to
d5 by Cardiff in Bishop captures an f1
Queen captures an f1 and the now comes
Bishop captures in c3 kurakin grabs the
pond and a six and we get this position
where Kerrigan has five points Maxine
has four points but it's bishops of
opposite colors and Kerrigan has a TT
point so carotene will try to push his a
pawn whereas Maxine will try to push his
C pawn and now usually a lot of people
say that Bishop and games are a draw
bishops of opposite colors but in such
rich positions where their Queens on the
board rooks on the board
the usual way is that the side that
attacks is like that side has is up a
piece because if you're attacking with a
light square Bishop your opponent cannot
use a dark square Bishop to repel the
lights for attacks so if it's a you know
just a nice Battle of lot of bishops of
opposite colors just attack that's
that's the rule we have Queen to g5 by
maksim going after the e3 pawn and now
Queen back to e to defending it cling to
a trade on pinning preparing f5 and the
King to g2 improving the position of the
king and with f5 now hurricane uses the
undefended Bishop on c3 to remain over
the Queen with Queen to d3
attacking the bishop bishop back the e5
and now rook to f1 again not allowing
captures because rook captures on f8
with check so King the g7 just now
defending the rookin f8 and now comes
each captures on f5 rook captures on f5
and now a for Kerrigan starts pushing
his passport and it's much easier for
him to push his passport than it is for
maxime as its it will be very hard to
pad the you know past the C 4 square
root captures an f1 King captures and
the now comes a very interesting move by
Machine Bishop to d4 he's of course
hoping for
for a captures and captures but if this
happens for example capture screen
captures then you can just start pushing
a5 but then see capture Sundy for and
now after a 60s white the past porn on
da file is very far ahead but you can
just go Queen each one check pick up the
h2 pawn and this game is a draw but
after Bishop to b4 correct and played
something else so feel free to pause the
video and try to find the move that car
can played in this position while I give
you a couple of seconds for those of you
who are able to do it congratulations
you are an excellent finder of moves in
games of opposite colored bishops and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show rush of the c4 this is the idea
the point is the point is that well and
many fold first off you cannot go Queen
captures on e3 because after Queen
captures and Bishop captures you push a
5 and now there's no stopping the point
the c5 pawn is blocked you cannot push
it back up to see four blocks and you
can't guard the a7 square which is the
only dark square this point has to cross
to become a queen and also you can go
Bishop f4 due to the g3 pawn to try and
prevent it with this maneuver so this is
completely lost you can't go for that on
the other hand after Bishop to c4 you
don't really have a good option bunch of
characters and III was played but it
doesn't really change anything the a
pawn is still going up the board Queen
to d7 check King h6 Queen h3 check first
King g7 and now Queen t6 are just nicely
centralizing the Queen also now a car
cane is ready to push his a pond and you
don't have any checks to give with black
so Bishop to d4 clearing the room for
the for the black queen now comes Queen
f7 check King to h6 and now a5 so you
allow a check or two but it's not a
problem as you can always hide King g2
King h3 so Bishop the f6 now allowing
checks along the F file and King to g2
not allowing with Queen to d2 check King
to h3 and now Queen back to g5
from there the Queen will be able to
deliver more check
quint the f8 check now comes the Bishop
to g7 and now Queen back to f3 which is
an excellent square for the Queen
not allowing Queen H 5 H 5 check not
alone whenever I've checked and also
keeping an eye on the a8 queening square
the bishop controls the a6 square so
really it will be impossible to stop
this point Bishop to d4 but now just a6
we have Queen to e7 guarding the a7
square but now comes Queen to d8 and
it's acquainted and it's not a problem
you can't deliver this check as the
bishop covers this square if you go here
then just King g2 and the Queen controls
this entire diagonal so any checks along
the light squares that will not be
possible go back to f6 by Maxine and now
a7 with Queen to d7 check and now even G
for Queen backed at east 7 and now of
course a very nice move by kurakin Queen
to f3 preparing a 8th Queen and also if
you capture on a7 then you lose the
bishop on f6 but there is no other move
we have Queen captures on a 7 Queen
captures on f6 and now Maxime still
doesn't resign he finds a very nice idea
Queen to a3 check and now what do you do
here also a very interesting idea
I feel free to pause the video and try
to find the winning move for white in
this position
well again give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations you are an excellent
avoider of stalemate and for those of
you who just wanna enjoy the show if you
found anything except blush of d3 or
Bishop b3 you will be losing this game
for example if if King gage for then
Queen to h3 check ensures stalemate now
you just capture and the black has no
moves you can't move the King you can't
move the pawn the pond is pinned at this
point cannot move
it's just stalemate it's the same if you
go King to g2 just Queen g3 check and
again if you capture it stalemate if
you're looking each one Queen g1 check
captures its again stalemate so
currently the only move he had but
should be three but it's not a problem
Queen captures and v3 with check and now
King to h4 of course the checkmate read
the stalemate resource is no longer
available if you deliver check why just
captures your queen you still have your
c-pawn that can be pushed so Maxine
could have resigned here but he you know
he was being a good sport and he'll out
Kirk in to finish the game in great
style Queen before offering a trade but
correct and just played Quinta f8 check
Queen blocks g7 and now of course comes
g5 and we have a checkmate on the board
which is very rare and you know Maxime
should definitely be congratulated on
allowing such a you know such a nice
presentation on the board as it's very
rare to see
checkmate on the board between two to
such LED grandmasters so that's that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it and
yeah it seems like I said it in the
beginning of the video everyone always
says Maxime is the best player in the
world when it comes to night off or when
it comes to the groom fall defense and
he almost always loses games in those
openings I mean not always he draws most
of them but he in top elite competitions
he loses them and that's exactly why
he's the best because he constantly
keeps searching for for really awesome
awesome active positions such as such as
this one and every time he plays a night
of that night of game against Fabiano
Caruana where he sacrifices to exchange
it's not one but two really just awesome
stuff so i really hope he he continues
with this play style as the games are
just just incredible you know even even
with a negative result here and there
but yeah once again I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank James
Norwood for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check too in my
previous videos see our think'll for
watching and I will see you soon we're
gonna check out one more game from round
8 of the sinful Cup and then we're gonna
check out the standings we're gonna
continue the cup 1 sorry guys soon as I
get the chance and of course checking up
on your suggestions so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
the rest of your day